this morning Saturday session Margo
price a 20-19 Grammy nominee for Best
New Artist her last album was hailed as
one of the best of the decade she'll
perform in just a moment but first
Anthony Mason spoke with Margo about why
her new record release was postponed
Nashville singer Margo price was getting
ready to release her third album this
spring when her husband guitarist Jeremy
IVs contracted the coronavirus how's
Jeremy doing he is finally in this just
this last week getting back to being
more like himself he was in a worse
state than I had ever seen him in my
whole life I mean he got thin and frail
and he was just sleeping like 12 to 14
hours a day and I was pretty terrified
[Music]
so price postponed her album release and
instead put out a collection of live
performances recorded at Nashville's
Ryman Auditorium in 2018
yeah I mean I think it's it's really
bittersweet to listen to because nobody
can play live shows and it just takes
you back to the feeling of like being
you know right there screaming in the
audience you miss that badly I do I miss
going to shows I miss being on stage I
miss being on tour I even miss airports
price spent 70 straight days in
quarantine caring for her husband and
their two kids Ramona is coming up on
her first birthday as we speak yes she
is I can hear her children actually it's
brought her closer she says to
one-year-old Ramona and nine-year-old
Judah I've never been able to spend this
much time with him and I am really
grateful that I have been able to see
every milestone with my daughter and
when they're that young they do change
every single day it's been a blessing in
disguise in that way and after all the
delays her new album that's how rumors
get started will now be released in July
so you are finally gonna put out your
album yes I really didn't know how to
self-promote in a pandemic and I still
don't know if I'm quite prepared for
that but I know that people are hungry
for music and art and way to escape
[Music]
and I just made a music video actually
in this room Margo price shot the video
for her new single letting me down with
a small socially distanced crew
[Music]
you have to try to make something good
out of something bad and in my life
that's kind of always been the pattern
tragedy and then processing and the
therapy of making it into art that's how
rumors get started comes out July 10th